hi guys I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey
uh wow what uh not just what a Monday
what a week it has been already since
then like last week was the Thousand
Oaks shooting and all the fire with a
Thousand Oaks is it were like in the
exact middle of where all the craziness
is we're in Sherman Oaks and if you guys
are not in LA Thousand Oaks is like 15
minutes from us one way and then the
fires are like 15 to 20 minutes the
other way oh yeah yeah and the fires are
happening yeah where the shooting
happened they're happening at the beach
they're happening yeah so it's it's it's
gnarly what's going on and you know like
really talk about any of those things
like to make youtube videos about it and
then Monday Stanley who you know there
were rumblings for like for a while now
how he's been ill he's 95 he's 95 he's
getting up in there and he passed away
today the age of 95 on today's date
November 12th and they're gnarly thing
about this is yeah it's really sad it's
it's really heartbreaking and and like
without you know exposing your personal
life too much you've had to deal with a
lot there's a lot of them death in your
life lately
yeah I've in my life I've dealt with a
pretty good amount of significant deaths
and the interesting thing about Stanley
is how do you put it like the guy's a
legend he's an icon an evil seal and
he'd lived like 95 is a pretty good age
you know yeah well he was a long time
yeah it still had a spry energy and a
cheeky sort of life about him you know
if kind of every time he popped up
despite health problems or whatever by
health aside all the crazy financial
stories that would come out - yeah steal
from him yeah keep him from his affairs
and stuff all
like awful things that he's had to
encounter yeah and the thing though is
his his legacy whoa
like what user where legend does not not
put lightly you know yeah the way how
like someone like the works of
Shakespeare who outlive us all is the
way San least will creations and work in
his contributions to outlive us all man
like God he it's he is an icon like you
should have a statue you know to a
degree I mean you could make the
argument that you know these characters
and these stories are a lot like you
know modern mythology and stuff so in a
way it's almost like Homer or somebody's
dying and leaving behind all these
mythical mythical things you know yeah a
birth so much and he not like if you
think about his work he helped
revolutionize obviously comic books but
not only that medium his works
revolutionized the movie and the movie
industry since Marvel Studios came to be
and made its stamp have completely
checked all right movie studios you know
this is all from his work and I can't
started when he was in his eighties and
it's not like he came up with something
and then his life was you know like
solid there was a long time where he was
not respected where he was broke or like
a long time it wasn't like he helped
pretty Marvel and these characters book
has not been the media know that it is
now for all of its life like he had
struggles and struggles before the comic
book medium was a thing of respect in
his world and then even in the movie
business when he tried getting movies
off the ground it just wasn't good in
the beginning and now look at what the
MCU is and how it's just affected so
many lives it becomes such a cultural
landmark you know without us covering
Marvel we wouldn't be where we are today
yes so much so my livelihood comes from
our various properties like most of
which Stanley either
created or had a hand in co-creating you
know so many of people's favorite
characters he's like you know Stanley's
work before you even know who Stanley is
exactly and he did stories about you
know there's a quote I heard ages ago
you know how does it go something about
like successful people are just ordinary
people who do extraordinary things
ordinary things extraordinarily well
yeah it's another version yeah yeah
that's it anyway so and with that in
mind it's like Stanley created these
characters who do extraordinary things
you know they like born with powers or
gifted powers whatever but if you look
at his life he was an ordinary guy who
birth extraordinary things you know like
he he this idea of extraord
extraordinary characters came from him
really working his ass off and putting
out this material that was really
shunned for such a long time and it's
one of those deaths where you feel
multiple things because one side is of
course the sadness and the heartbreak
and you know I'm sure they got some
Marvel cameo shot already they want to I
want that but it's like even with the
Marvel movies it's like we're that
Stanley camera just expected it's never
like an eye roll the movies that are
like really really serious and you know
not as much on the cheeky side it's
still the moment of levity can just be
seeing Stanley yeah man yes reassuring
face and he does seem like one of those
guys who just had that life of like you
just kind of keep working and doing your
thing until the end you know and that
keeps you young in a way cuz this is
always the inspiring thing about Stanley
is like no matter what age it seems I've
seen him at he's always got that magical
sparkle in his eye and that magical
demeanor and I feel like if you look at
the comics too I mean the
easy comparison to make is that you know
DC and Marvel being the two titans DC
stuff is a bit more dark and a lot of
people love what Marvel is because
there's such a human element and such a
relatable own characters like spider-man
that are so every Manish is so kind of
sentimental in a way as well as fun and
quippy and badass and all that stuff
yeah I feel like so much of Stanley's
spirit comes out in the tambour of the
Marvel Comics oh yeah voice of the
Marvel comic because he he had this
energy about him and like he as much as
fun as it was to read a Marvel comic or
watch his characters on the big screen
like watching a Stan Lee interview was
always fun it's a pleasure to meet ya
gotta spite of humans see ya like I I've
not only heard countless people talk
about meeting Stan Lee through like the
internet or whatever and I've met so
many people whether it be they work in
this YouTube medium or they work in the
movie news medium or just fans people
who are just fans who go to comic-con
but met Stan Lee and I cannot think of
one time one time where anyone was like
the guys at the guy's a jerk no once
okay countless people will talk about
how they'll like engage in conversation
with him and people always want his
attention you know and hey it seems like
he's happy
no matter what level of success he had
he was humbled because of the fact that
he had so much struggle yeah to get to
where the success is now and that it's
like the characters outlive him but now
it but his sample outlive us all oh you
know yeah yeah and I think in his own
way I mean he's definitely gonna be
remembered for a good long while
especially never gonna be forgotten no I
mean so one of the greats yeah so much
of our modern pop culture landscape has
to do with the doors that Marvel Comics
open with the further expansions into TV
and cartoons and then movies like I
don't think anything would look the same
if you removed Marvel and Star Wars
the spectrum you know well I mean with
that in mind Stanley may rest in peace
you've you've done a great job in this
world like you've you you've made and
that's like you beyond and like with the
idea of what entertainment medium is the
his work is so personal for it's not
only affected the careers of people like
the audience's and everyone they think
it's so personal it's touched people
yeah inspired people and it will
continue hey oh yeah oh yeah that's the
thing is like that's a legacy right
there that he's left behind and he lived
a long time and you know prayers with
the family that he left behind all the
close ones that he's left behind cuz of
course he has you know family members
days left behind so condolences to them
but at the same time just it's it's a
it's like a it's like completing a novel
yeah it's a it's a it's a very unique
death to me of yeah of like like oh that
you can't say this guy didn't complete
not like is it's what he's done it will
just it's ripple effect it's gonna last
for forever think about and you just
kind of imagine that he'll never die
yeah right yeah I'm hearing it now it's
weird it's like I am sad to hear it but
at the same time I almost feel like he's
not like as much as we try to comfort
ourselves and be like oh people aren't
gone in one way or another this feels
the most like ever Stanley Brazil I
don't he may not be on earth with us
anymore but his life and his energy
lives on through a man and and yeah it
does kind of feel like the completion
it's like I'm not even sad because he's
gotten to see this start from nothing
grow into one of the biggest comic
companies and then to complete like the
ten years of the MCU just recently and
have infinity war come out and all this
huge success realize it's like I got to
imagine that even at the very end it's
like mission accomplished to you exactly
I think that's what makes this a very
unique feeling yeah it's like ice like
yeah I feel warm but also sad but warm
yeah you know because you're like that's
even the fact that he died is that
reminder of like that's the kind of life
I guess I would want to want to sort of
live you know feeling like his person
dies in you're like well damn they
created something so important and it's
getting too long Joey you know yeah I
can't really put it into words it's so
it's so unique and you know cuz a lot of
times if like someone dies at a young
age or like oh they had so much left to
do there's so much more they could have
completed or but it's like to live this
long and to go out in a way where you're
like the highest note ever and it's
gonna just keep going Wow see ya amazing
and so yeah like you said sad and warm
simultaneously and let's all just keep
remembering the great that he provided
for us yeah
prayers to the family and Thank You
Stanley for all you've contributed to
this world